the title is man who jumped to his death
at Disneyland was principal of accused
child endangerment
so this guy
um Christopher Christensen
who was a principal for Huntington Beach
Elementary School or looks like several
schools for 22 years
um was Drew was due for a court a
pre-trial conference hearing on Monday
for the two misdemeanor charges which he
directly blamed for suicide and a
lengthy Facebook post I'll read that in
a minute
uh just before you leave from the Mickey
and Friends parking garage imagine going
all the way to Disneyland
to make this display for people to see
um very you know
I'm not even going to go there you know
where I'm you know what I'm starting to
think about I'm not going to read the
parts of the posts we'll get to that
this is this is a gentleman over here
um who is a principal also apparently a
talented musician but he
you know guys look the whole red flag
thing and I'm going to drop this again
the whole red flag thing the ticker's
below
don't watch my podcast don't buy the
book I don't give a [__] at least read
this chapter on red flag so you
understand the kind of women that you
don't want to invite in your life that
can potentially cause Havoc especially
if you're a plugged in dude and you know
you're not ready to see all the truth
that unplugging offers you
um
one of the big problems that he dealt
with was he invited a single mommy into
his life
um there's a few other red flags too as
we kind of get into the photographs
which I'll talk about as well but uh
these are all excerpts from the post
this is a long post over here which I'll
read in a minute
this is him and his his wife they had a
private marriage it wasn't public
apparently
um
and there's more excerpts from the post
this is him now bright purple like
brightly colored hair color like this
sign of feminism typically you know
conventionally feminine women don't dye
their hair weird colors like this this
is another red flag okay
um red flag number two is feminists uh
red flag number I'm looking at my list
over here so many damn there's 20 of
them number 12. single mommies uh I'm
sure there's more as we kind of you know
dive down and investigate this uh that's
the building that apparently or it
happened at and I don't know what's
going on over here this is just
Disneyland stuff anyway so let me go
over to his uh Facebook post
and I'll just kind of read it to you
because rather than doing what most guys
would do which would just be like you
know do it and be done with it he wrote
onto Facebook on a public post to tell
the world I'm actually surprised it's
still up at this point I mean it's a
public post but you know to go and tell
the world that this is why he was doing
what he was doing so his post reads
uh actually let me just switch over to
this side it's probably easier um
he goes on to say I hate when people
leave this earth with so many unanswered
questions so I hope this provides some
insight and perspective
this is my wife Marlena Yes you heard me
correctly most of you don't know this
but we privately married three and a
half years ago now
her last name is not Christensen on
Facebook it's something else I'm not
going to tell you what it is because
there's weirdos out there and she
doesn't need to be harassed as a result
of this but
um
I found her Facebook profile and any
public photograph she has is just her
and her two little girls no pictures
with him now I've often said to you guys
in in the past in other
uh videos or podcasts one of the Dead
giveaways of a beta mail is their
Facebook profile picture any social
media picture is him and his chick
together
um and then you click through onto hers
and there's no mention or no obvious
signs that she's in a relationship with
a guy at all
he's making it very clear that she's an
important piece or fixture in his life
but on her social media she makes she
has has made no indication from what I
can see anyway that he's an important
fixture in her life it was just her or
her and her two little kids so
anyway he goes on and says uh she and I
love and adore each other and our
relationship has been amazing up until
recently unfortunately two weeks ago she
and I got into a heated argument at home
in front of the girls tempers were
flared and strong words were exchanged
between us however never in this
exchange did I hit slap or hurt Marlena
or or in any manner nor did I ever touch
the girls I have never and I never will
I love the girls like my own so these
are not his girls he's I don't know
adopted them or whatever but she's a
single mom she she showed up in his life
with two kids from a prior relationship
looking at her Facebook kind of when you
scroll back through the timeline it
looks like there's family photos of her
and that and the girl's father around
2014-15
so shortly after that I guess whatever
she left him or something happened and
then she connected with this new uh beta
provider
anyway I love the girls like my own and
they and they know that as does anyone
else who truly knows me unfortunately
Marlena's anger got the best of her that
night and she called the police which
landed me in jail that night they don't
ask questions the cops don't ask
questions they just remove the threat
from the house even if it's a weak
looking beta mail they'll just remove
them from the house usually for the
evening lock them up and then there's
some sort of charges or bail or
something sort of time it depends on
where you live in the state or Province
but they don't need proof they don't
need to show the police when they arrive
at the house bruises scars Cuts video
footage nothing all she has to do is say
he bad man he threatened and then they
take him away in handcuffs out of your
house uh it's it's it's guilty first and
then let's prove the Innocence later
that's how law Works in a female first
primary social order talk about this a
little bit in chapter one of my book of
the unplugged Alpha so shouldn't be new
to you guys if you've been following me
for a while anyway anyway so dude spends
the night in jail yes me a man who has
never hit or harmed anyone in his life I
think it's safe to say that Marlena
truly regrets making that call because
the events of that night have completely
unraveled both of our lives I'm on the
brink of losing my job now he's a school
principal if you're charged with
misdemeanors or being a threat to the
lives of children you obviously can't
remain a principal anymore so not only
did he spend a night in jail but he was
probably either suspended or there was
some consequence to her making this call
on him and him Landing in jail I don't
know if he lost a job or was was
suspended but this is where he's at
regrets the call because the events that
night have completely unraveled both of
our Lives when truthfully he's talking
about his life not really hers I'm sure
there was no consequences to her life
otherwise she would have been doing the
same thing that he did I am on the brink
of losing my job and I am out on
administrative leave okay so there you
go so they suspended him until my case
is resolved which in some cases could be
months or even beyond that maybe even a
year or more however the legal system is
extremely flawed especially against men
fathers well why did you invite a single
mommy into your house right like you can
avoid a lot of these problems by not
making silly choices that expose you to
unnecessary risk anyway he goes on and
says it's sickening how quickly and
easily an innocent man can be thrown in
jail because of zero evidence or proof
all right well
what have I been saying for years guys
in fact take a look at the attached
screenshots of Marlena's message to my
friend about this matter she too had no
intention of leaving sorry she had no
intention on having that night come this
far she knows I would never hurt her or
the girls and she too has been trying to
clear my name with little success again
the legal system is deep so he's blaming
the legal system it's all the legal
system's fault
so here I am writing my final Facebook
post to all of you
I bet nobody 20 years ago thought to
themselves oh one day people will write
a final Facebook post before they take
permanent steps to a temporary problem
in their life
like this is where we are today right
you know to broadcast this stuff
anyway
um I need you to I need you all to know
that a gentle kind loving and sincerely
good man has been destroyed by one
unfortunate night it really is
unfortunate this is not me this is not
something that I ever thought would
happen to me with all of this said I
have truly loved educating and leading
thousands of students and families as a
principal and fvsd whatever that is for
the past 21 plus years I've made so many
wonderful connections with families over
the years and those who know me closely
know how much I cared for my students
staff and families please remember me
for all the good I brought in the world
of Education to all my musician friends
thank you thank you for performing with
me over the last 30 years we've had a
blast performing over and creating such
fun like
like over this like over this you know
your life stops it full stop here over
some chick and a false DV charge
anyway the day job I'm sad to say last
night was my final performance oh boy
however it went very well and I'm proud
of my final performance was a success
I've always loved performing especially
during the holiday season I'm going to
miss it dearly there's so much more I
want to say that I'm going to spend the
rest of today reaching out to those
closest to me and let them know how much
I love them this is not an ideal way to
go out but at least I get a chance to
say some final words of those who I love
in the door take care everyone please
please please be kind to one another
treat each other with kindness and Grace
there's too much anger in the world and
people need to start treating each other
better what I've shared with you is a
prime example of how anger can really
have a long lasting extremely damaging
effect on a person's life and you put
some photographs here of him in his uh
wife check thing
um this is a public post so there's
loads of comments here from randoms just
sort of chiming in on the matter but
look guys
this is why you need to end the beta
okay this is why you need to unplug from
society's comforting lies I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out